following the success of the inaugural
agilent precision oncology virtual
summit held in may 2021 we will be
hosting a second installation the
ashland ignite hope precision oncology
virtual summit to be held on may 19 2022
precision oncology has transformed many
aspects of the journey to understanding
and defeating cancer
from detection to diagnosis patient care
and disease monitoring agilent believes
in continuous education and partnership
and that includes bringing together
industry trends latest advancements
thought leaders and dynamic idea
exchanges into a common platform join us
at the precision oncology virtual summit
as we collaborate with international key
opinion leaders to discuss topics
including translational insights and the
future of precision oncology
the use of liquid biopsies for lymphoma
research and diagnostic applications
clinically significant biomarkers in
personalized medicine a tissue-based
multiplex biomarker assay as a key
advancement in tissue pathology
don't miss the opportunity to discover
new insights that will bring hope to
cancer patients around the world
see you at the ashland ignite talk
precision oncology virtual summit